hello everybody my name is markiplier hi
decrepid Oh Bree the alright so welcome
to Madison now this is a horror game
that I okay know what
whenever I look down the hallway and I'm
filled with a okay long story short I'm
not going in there long story long what
the hell's happening here I I don't know
anything about this game other than that
it's called Madison and this is a demo
for it that's locked okay alright I'm
high that's new that wasn't like that
before with the tarp and the picnic
blanket okay hello Polaroid point shoot
print
shake
you get a good look at this will be
really get a sniff on this one okay all
right God wrapped it what okay got
Polaroid got a breath this is it notify
that your child Luke Maxwell is hereby
expelled from Westlake secondary school
the situation is out dangerous hello boy
who was stabbed went to the police
Chris charges get your child Oh
oh no my child stab someone
why did my child stab someone all right
just so we're on the same page
[Music]
shut up I don't know what you want for
me but shut up and go away clankity
clankity you know what I'm not gonna
deal with you I didn't think I was gonna
go down here but it looks like I have to
here we go Oh who saw her you got jiggly
for a second now let me just cruise back
here why who builds a house like this
also I did that now glad I did that
never I'd do that again with clicking
drag now closed there blam oh there's a
lot of creaky squeaky's going on this
goes on I don't like that but I got a
key and I can only assume that it's to
this let's see yeah yep that looks good
okay
all right let's use it study key I'm
really trying
oh oh they're saying to study this is
not a study of you sitting there was
that football helmet what's going on
what's happening here that a present for
me Oh grandpa
you ain't look so good Madison is that
you all right okay and I seem to be
guiding myself into a world of hurt let
me take a look at grandpa all right you
know what I changed my mind
I don't wanna be here grandpa are you
doing whoa its color oh hi
why did I stuff that it you turned I
don't like any of that yeah hi Paul
man that is an unflattering picture
Albert Meyers well okay oh whoa it's
just like dad what you always walk
around the beats shirtless with okay all
right the items were paintings by
Picasso as well as some gold and diamond
jewelry oops the worthy whizz miss
hell's precious and sting camera which
has finally found an evil owner it's
been 30 years since then at organist
multiple murders and in spite of
numerous options of the family assets no
one had previously purchased your camera
for viewers unfamiliar with the story
Madison hell killed her own family
drinking witchcraft ceremony she was
then fatally shot in the stomach by a
police officer would commonly act and
now for the weather
that does sound like a Jim Gardner Blair
Jose you all right fine stop being a
little [ __ ] baby okay all right all up
in this present day birthday present
but how does it get here we I'm Luca
wait I'm Luca wait I stabbed a kid
oh I'm the badass oh hell yeah
ah look so good that doesn't look so
good at all okay whoo it's a lot of
noises coming from over there
this you wait oh I don't like camera
mode but there's some film over there
all right camera mode yeah yeah yeah yay
all righty let's take a nice picture
here boom holy [ __ ] what the [ __ ] shake
it
ah there we go that's so uh well huh
that's peculiar
how about that that's weird weird all
right Oh new screen awesome
Polaroid's brave Oh play this game a
little played I don't want to play it I
do not want to play oh you are you good
there's some missing paintings from
there okay ah I don't have a password
okay thank you I can't I can't do
anything okay all right I'll come back
later
go go into camera mode nope that okay
there is camera mode okay alrighty then
Oh Lee dad take a picture boom
nothing great perfect exactly what else
over you bye
I don't want any I don't want any Oh
I don't there's nothing in the hallway
okay there's something in the hallway
all right
why am I doing this why are you here why
why would I do this why would I do this
I don't want to do this a little weird
all right don't work
dark dark hi hello oh hello okay
no nothing I don't know what you want
from me there used to woo Hey Oh
all right how about you when did I Oh
I want to look around for something else
first what do you mean whatever I wanna
look why are you so calm
se10 shipping i don'twant oh when did
you get back to normal
you were ass bag
okay all right
Oh got a nail I don't know why I have a
nail but I got a nail oh do I need a
nail to be able to hang this thing up
there okay oh [ __ ]
well I took a picture see nothing I'm a
fool I'm a goddamn fool and you scared
the piss out of me but you were your ass
Oh [ __ ] oh okay all right let me put
a nail oh let me put a nail yep there we
go Kurt just like that yeah baby just
like that blue yeah that looks good
Gramps you've never looked better real
proud of you okay so what do I do about
that
what's the point what's the point of
hanging this up oh maybe I should take a
picture every now oh I'm sorry you don't
point that finger at me pillows sonny
jim whoo that's not good that's not good
that is not good don't point your dirty
finger me or are you warning me Oh
okay about the key okay all right oh
that was sugar ha ha ha ha ah that was
so good that was so good it was
terrifying I crapped my pants oh man
that was good
well that was the demo from Madison I'm
gonna follow up on this this game needs
me some because this game was full of
scary and spooky and I loved it so let
me know what you thought everybody down
the comments below thank you everybody
so much for watching if you got other
horror games you want me to play let me
know down in the comments thanks again
and as always in the next video bye bye
[Music]